the property market right now in the uk
is
absolutely booming it's blowing
up right move has recently said that
house prices are going up faster now
than they have historically over the
last five years there's
parts of the country parts of merseyside
and liverpool
that have gone up in the last 12 months
by 15
that is crazy there's parts of the south
around um you know outskirts of london
that have gone up dramatically
rents are going crazy so what is the
opportunity for you
my advice would be even though property
market is booming
and house prices are going up like crazy
never buy a house
and rely on capital appreciation never
buy a house and just think oh because
it's boom the last 12 months
it's going to continue to do that
because it might not
so when you're buying a property always
make sure that you're buying for
cash flow rather than capital
appreciation
i had a friend that bought a property
recently a few months back
for 24 and a half thousand pounds
in bishop auckland she spent a couple
thousand on it
it's boomed it's now worth 50
000 pounds it's doubled in a few months
now she did buy it below market value i
went out i looked at the property
i've seen i was like can i see the title
deeds and the mortgage
lender's new valuation on this because
it just seems unrealistic it's going
crazy
another thing as well is if you're
looking to buy a property
buy properties in the areas that maybe
haven't quite boomed just yet
some of the areas that are just catching
on now that are just trending now
many people have been really surprised
by the housing
market in the uk booming despite going
through a recession
the pandemic the lockdown so why has
that happened and i think there's a few
reasons as to why it's happened
the first reason is because they've been
actively encouraging people to invest in
property
with things like the stamp duty holidays
and they've also been actively
encouraging home buyers
as well as investors i think the second
reason is
interest rates are still very low and
the banks are lending money actively to
investors to first-time buyers
you can fix interest rates for five
years sometimes even up to 10 years
they've kept the base rate at 0.1
percent which is
crazy the low has just been for hundreds
of years
and i think the third reason is because
a lot of people are moving house
and when people are moving house when
house sales are happening
it usually pushes the prices up and the
reason people are moving house is
because they're relocating back to home
they're maybe now working from home
instead of an office and
what's going to happen in the future
well some of those things are going to
stop
the stamp duty holiday at some point is
gonna stop but some of those things are
gonna continue
like i i think that people are gonna
continue relocating
for potentially the next year or so
because
a lot of businesses are now telling
their staff
that they can now work from home on a
permanent basis which is meaning people
are moving home
people are upsizing downsizing people
are moving outside of london into the
country
so there's a lot of movement happening
in the market which is going to keep the
prices up and also interest rates i
think interest rates are gonna creep
up but i think they're gonna i think
they're gonna stay low for
quite a long time on the basis that the
banks are letting you
fix them for quite a long time if
they're about to hike them massively
in the coming months they wouldn't let
you fix them for five
ten years so what am i doing right now
in the market
and what would i suggest that you
potentially do well what i would say is
as as you've probably heard before don't
wait
to buy property buy property and wait
as long as you're buying properties that
cash flow positive and you're not
relying on capital appreciation
because no one knows exactly what's
going to happen i think that now
is a very very good time to buy as long
as you buy strategically and you buy the
right properties in the right area
now the reason i think it's a good time
to buy now is because they are printing
more and more money we've now printed
895 billion
pounds now what are the banks doing with
the money they're lending it out to
people
to invest to buy but as they're printing
more money
things are shooting up you may notice
that a lot of things are going up in
price a lot
things are going up that might be food
petrol cars everything's going up
in price and the reason that things are
going up is because
money is becoming worth less so if
you've got
say ten thousand pounds to buy a car if
that ten thousand pounds
if they suddenly print a lot more money
you can get less for your money
which means that the car goes up so
as people are saving money it is it is
rapidly reducing in value and becoming
worth less and less over time that's
what i would advise
if you have money in the bank get it out
put it into an asset that's gonna
potentially go up in value
it's gonna definitely hold its value but
it's also gonna produce cash flow
there's properties at the moment in the
uk where you can buy them cheaper than
you can build them
it's unlikely that they're gonna crash
even when the crash does happen
and people say what do you mean the
crash is gonna happen and get all scared
and worried
but it's completely normal for
properties to go up and then go down and
then go
up and then go down but if you buy and
if you buy right you're gonna have an
asset that's gonna hold its value
over the long term and produce you cash
flow
so those are my thoughts about the
property market right now in 2021
let me know what you think in the
comment section if you enjoy my content
please do me a big favor and hit the
like button subscribe for more videos
and i'll see you guys next time
you